well Venezuela's embattled president is
under new pressure after more of
America's European allies called for
Nicolas Maduro to be replaced at least
38 countries now support opposition
leader Juan Guido China and Russia are
maderos main supporters right now and
this morning russia's Foreign Minister
called for talks between the government
and the opposition Elizabeth Palmer is
in Venezuela where Roman Catholic
leaders are helping maduras opponents
and others who just want to survive
misery and hardship affects almost
everybody in this country from end to
end but we decided to go and have a look
up close at one little community on the
outskirts of Caracas called la Vega mass
in la Vega not only fills the church it
draws an overflow crowd here father
alfredo and Fantas spiritual message
carries a strong political subtext s
mensaje anthem
Maduro it's not directly anti Maduro he
tells me people have to decide it
themselves but the church has called his
presidency unconstitutional his
parishioners might call it something
else
a disaster father Infanta takes me
deeper into the slum where there's been
no running water for four months the
church is also behind this sidewalk free
lunch program potatoes cheese and a dose
of vitamins if not for this some of
these kids wouldn't eat at home with
average inflation last year a surreal
80,000 percent almost no one in La Vega
or anywhere else in Venezuela can
survive on what they need to work the
economy here is so broken that say the
average teacher's salary
six dollars a month would only buy this
in fact almost half of Venezuela we're
to be seriously hungry without some kind
of charity or food meet is a treat
ask Henrique the butcher who's still in
business though the customers are fewer
and fewer he's an exception here
he supports Maduro and he is furious the
US has got involved every country he
tells me that the US has so-called
helped has ended up with misery and
destruction but that's an opinion you
hear less and less especially as huge
quantities of humanitarian aid from the
United States approaches Venezuela's
borders for CBS this morning I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in caracas venezuela
research rich country on the verge of
being a real fail state